八十三番 サッバッタヴェーサップリサーワジャンティ
ナカーマカーマラパヤンティサントー
スケーナプッタアッタワドゥケーナ
ナウッチャーワチャンパンディターダッサヤンティ
サッバッタヴェーサップリサーワジャンティ
ナカーマカーマラパヤンティサントー
スケーナプッタアッタワドゥケーナ
ナウッチャーワチャンパンディターダッサヤンティ
えーと 意味は ちょっと注釈書の意味っていうのはね
ちょっと見本屋ありますかね
はい  何？ ん？ これの  矯正する
はい  これは まあ注釈書の意味はなかなか大変悩みに注釈していますからね
まあ大体みんなこの言葉の意味だけしか翻訳してはないと思いますね
サッバッタヴェーサップリサーワジャンティ
サップリサーっていうのは善
善 善人のことですね いわゆる悟りに達していた人々のことなんですね
サッバッタっていうのはどこでもという意味で
行かなるところ どんなところでも
善人たちがまあ歩いても
行っても ナカーマカーマラパヤンティサントー
まああれが欲しい これが欲しくないとかね
そういうことはないんですね
好き嫌いとかね まあ私たちもあちこちは出たりしますけど
やっぱり好き嫌い激しいんですね
散歩にしたっても あの辺はあまり良くないとか
ここら辺散歩しましょうとかね
という やっぱりいつでも好き嫌いっていうのはあるんですね
まあ買い物するならば
やっぱり商店街の方がやめましょうとかね
どこでもいいやっていうことはないんです
いろいろ旅行に行っても
旅行に行ったり 動いたりする場合は
どうせもう好き嫌いでやってるんです
で 必ず好きなところを選んで行くわけでもないんですけど
まあすごい険しいところ
難しいところにも行ったりはしますけど
やっぱりまあそうするとその制覇することが
その厳しい山を制覇しましたと
いう感じで まあわざと嫌いなところを選んだりしたりして
やっぱり好き嫌いで生きてるんですね
だから聖者たちも一箇所で一日しか止まらなく歩くんですけど
まるっきりあの場所いい
この場所はあまり良くないということは全くないんです
何か要求することも何もないんです
この精神状態なんですね
暑いんだから寒いところに散歩に行こうという
それ要求してるんですね
そういう全くもう こういうその気持ちさえもないんだよと
スケーナプッタアッタワドゥケーナ
まあ苦しみ 苦しみ スケーナっていうのは楽しい
まあ楽しいことがあっても
苦しいことがあっても
ナウッチャーワチャン
心の動揺 心は上がったり下がったりすることは
パンディター 賢者にはないんだよと
[笑い]ということで
注釈書で言っているのは
この五蘊に対してなんですね
まあ五蘊の中でいかなるものにしても
阿羅漢になった人々は
欲は持たないんだよというかなり難しい解説するんですね
おそらくそれ強引かもしれませんね
ウッダカ長老の うーん
どうしようかと困りますけど
まあ一応説明しますけど
このサッバというパーリの言葉があります
サッバ SABBA サッバっていうのは一切という意味なんですね
全てという意味なんですね
で よく使う単語ですよ
全て 一切という この全てといっても
一般人が思う意味じゃないんですね
仏教の意味は で まあ意味はかなり違います
仏教で全てっていうのはこの五蘊のことですね
五蘊っていうのは色蘊
受蘊 想蘊 行蘊と また認識の識なんですね
肉体と感覚と もう考え方と
衝動という心の気持ちと
知る機能ですね その 5つで生命ができているんですね
だから いかなる生命であろうとも
たとえ神であろうとも
人間であろうとも 動物であろうとも
もう幽霊であろうが 餓鬼道であろうとも
一切の生命は まあ五蘊でできているのです
無色界という梵天だけ色蘊がないんです
いわゆる物体がないんです
それ以下 みんなもう体を持っています
体は物質で 体があって感覚がある
それから感覚に 感覚からいろいろ想という概念が作ったりする
感じたものはこれ感じたと思ったりする
それから次にどうしましょうかという衝動も生まれる
それをまとめてこの知ることになりますから
色蘊とも言うんですね
だから体と心という 2つなんですね
それは五蘊 五蘊という
もういつでも使っている単語で
これを覚える しかないんです
もう覚えて暗記しないと仏教はなかなか難しくなっちゃうんですね
喋るのも だから全ての生命を知ってるんだぞというと
一般人が考える思考で幻想現象で考えるんですね
それではもう知ることはできないんです
地球上の人間のことをみんなのこと知りますよと思ったって
これはもう無理に決まってます
で どれぐらい人がいることも知らないし
その一人一人のことを調べて知っておくとも時間かかるし
だから一つの村でも一生かけても終わりにならないかもしれません
生命のそうやって現象で知るっていうことはありえないんですね
人のことは我々もそれほど知らないんですね
家族したっても 家族は一生ずっと一緒に生活しているんですけど
お互いそんなに知らないんです
全部知ってるっていうことはならないんです
知らないものは結構あるんですね
だからそうやって家族のことは知り尽くしますとか
何とかっていうのは そこはもうありえない話です
だから そういう不可能なことを無知的な挑戦しますよ
人間は 子供のことはなら何でも知ってるぞと思ってますけど
それは勘違いで 子供のことにしたっても知らない方が多いんです
知っているところよりは
そういうわけで 自分の子供であっても
我々は知っている量よりは知らない方がたくさんあります
知ることも不可能なんで
子供は学校でいる時間長いんですけど
どんな風にいるのか どうやっても知ることできないんですよ
じゃあ親も暮らして一緒に学校に行くんですかね
で 学校終わるまで見張っていくんですかね
これはありえないし 親が学校に行った途端
雰囲気がまだ変わるんですよ
その時子供がやっていることで
うちの子はいつでも学校でこんなことやってるの？と
それは勘違いで 親がいない時にやるのかと
また違いますよね だから自分の子供のことでも知ることは不可能です
知る一部は知ってますけど
たくさんのことは知らないっていうことは正しいやり方なんです
正しいんです だから人を知るっていうことさえもありえないんです
一切の生命のことを知るっていうことも
そのやり方では この無知なやり方ではありえないんです
だからお釈迦様は科学的なアプローチで
生命っていうのは五蘊でできているんだよと
この構成を分析してみるんですね
それにはサンプル一つ取っちゃえば十分です
だからサンプルとして自分の体を取ってみるんで
自分の体には五蘊があるんだよと
五蘊以外何もないんだよと
それで他の人の体も五蘊以外何もない
犬の体にも五蘊しか何もないんですね
そこで五蘊を知り尽くすんです
五蘊を知り尽くしたら
一切の生命を知り尽くしたことになるんです
それが一切を知る方法なんです
すごい具体的で論理的で
田中さんも田中さんも何さんも何さんも知りますよと
これはもうありえないんです
しかし 俗世間はそういうふうに知りたいんですよ
だから俗世間の知る方法っていうのは
最初の一歩でも不完全で誤解で
いや 私は人間のことを知ってやるぞと思って
じゃあまず初めに自分の子供のことから始まりますよと
そこででも終わる できないんだからね
一番身近にいるところから始まりますよと
そこ終わってから隣の家の人のことを知ることにするぞと
成り立ちませんよ だから何でも知りたがる俗世間が何も知らないんです
アプローチは間違っているんですね
お釈迦様はそういうやり方はダメですよと
これを法則で見るんですよと
生命たるものは五蘊ですと
それで五蘊を知った人は生命のことは知っている
だから仏教で一切というのは五蘊のことなんです
五蘊 一切とは五蘊であるとお釈迦様ははっきりと教えられてあります
それがすごい論理的な答えなんです
五蘊は知り尽くすことはできません
だって自分にも五蘊がありますから
人のことで心配する必要ないんです
よく自分のことなら知ります
自分には感覚ありますから
感覚ってどういうものかと自分で知ることはできるし
だからこの何も介入する必要もないし
何か道具を使う必要もないんです
メーターで数字を計算する必要はないんです
自分の感覚はもう明確に瞬時に知ってますから
自分の感情 気持ちは明確に瞬時に知ってますからね
そこでその法則を調べてみると
それで生命のことをよく知ってることになるんです
ということで この注釈書では
このサブバット すべてのところっていうことは五蘊のことであるっていう風には注を入れてあるんですね
サップリサっていうのは
阿羅漢の方々はワジャンティっていうのは歩くっていう意味なんですけど
このもうこれは縄張りの範囲のことだそうですね
研究分野みたいな感じで
ワジャっていう言葉を使う場合は
単純に足で歩くっていう意味だけでもないんです
だから 阿羅漢に達した聖者の研究範囲はもう五蘊であると
そういうことで 阿羅漢に達したっていうことは
この この煩悩をなくすっていうことは
この  五蘊に対するチャンダラーで欲を捨てるんですね
この欲っていうことがこの期待することなんですね
希望することなんですね
例えば肉体に対する欲と言えば
もっと痩せてほしい もっと体重減ってほしいとかね
あれこれと体に対していろんな期待を作るんですね
だから この肉体を評価する人が肉体にいろいろ要求するんですね
なぜ肉体に要求する 肉体から何か自分にはいいことがあるんだぞと思ったりするんです
しかし その要求っていうのは不可能で
ですよ で 死んでからもこういう人になりたいとかね
将来まで要求するんですね
今もこういうこういう体でいたいと
どうしてもあります その
その そこはチャンダラーガというんですね
で 感覚にしたってもいろいろ要求するんですよ
この音楽は聴きたくないと
しかし こういう音楽は聴きたいとか
で そこでこの感覚ですね
音で感覚が生まれるんですよ
そこで感覚が自分がいろいろ要求するんだから
音を選んだりするんです
この音はいや この音は好きと
なぜならば 嫌という思った音が別な感覚を作って
好きという音が別な感覚を作るんですね
だから自分がその感覚が欲しいんだから
期待するんだから 音楽を選んだりすると
見るものを選んだりする
食べ物を選んだりすると
で 感覚に要求する それで概念にもいろいろ要求があるんですね
もっと勉強したいとかね
もっといろんなことを知りたいとかね
で それは想蘊に対するチャンダラーガで
行蘊も同じこと でもいろんなことをやりたいんですね
やりたいという気持ちも人間も結構持っていたりしてね
何かに挑戦しなきゃ面白くないっていうかね
やることがなかったらもう大変苦しいんですね
だからやることあるというこの衝動があったら
みんな楽しい 元気やということになっちゃって
だからいつでもやりがいとかね
やりがいとかね この衝動がもう燃えてほしいんですね
それで この常にある五蘊の一部である行蘊に対して期待
チャンダラーガしているんです
欲 まあそれから認識ということが
とにかく認識する 知るということはずっとありまして
それも返って期待するんですね
で こういうものは知りたくない
こういうものを知りたいとか
認識についても あの かなり意欲があるんです
まあ例えば何かもう好きで何か本を読んだところで
もうなかなか難しくてわからなかった
わからなかったとすると
もっと明確にわかればいいなとかね
明確に理解したいとか
もう気持ちが生まれてくる
一部の人々にはね こんな本がわかりませんだから捨てますよというのは
随分みんな簡単にやってますけどね
そういうことだったら知識は成長しませんしね
だから世界で一番本を読む国民ですけど
世界のことを一番知らない国でもあります
で こんなのわからない
難しい もういいや あの本はと
もう随分勝手に捨てちゃいますね
挑戦して見てみようっていうことはない
読んでみようっていうことはないんですね
だから漫画ばっかりになっちゃうんです
とにかく認識の場合でも
我々は期待は持っている
良くなりたいと その五蘊に対するこのチャンダラーガ
欲を捨てることが まあ悟りということになるんですね
だから五蘊を捨てることじゃなくて
五蘊に対する欲を捨てる
それがナカマカマラペヤンティサント
あれ欲しい これ欲しくないということが出てこないんだよと
そういう意味で解説はしています
先生 その欲っていうのはいつもあるんですか？ ん？ ずっとあるんですか？欲っていうのは
ん？ 欲 欲 欲っていうのはずーっと繋がってる
常に 五蘊に対して  ないことはないんです
うん ですから 体に対して楽が生まれても
体に心に楽が楽しみが生まれても
苦しみが生まれなくても
別に全然もう冷静でいられるのだという
この悟りの境地を説明している経典ですね
ストーリーはあまりよくないな
ストーリーもありますけど
ストーリーで入るとちょっと芸の意味が落ちるんですけどね
お釈迦様がこのある庵に入ってね
ウェーランジャーという街で
これは有名な話でね 戒律のテキストが出てきて
あるバラモンが庵に入ってくださいとお願いはして
家に帰って忘れちゃったんですね
で 大体大体人ぐらい もう人たくさんのご本たちも一緒にいたし
で 忘れちゃって まあそれで朝托鉢に出たら
もう誰ももう習慣も何もないしね
何も食事をもらわなかったんですね
だからこれが大変でしょうしね
1日1食でしょうし で
比丘たちは何のことなく
まあ習慣というかね 決まりですから
午前中は街に入って托鉢に回って
自分が住んでいるところに戻る
また次の日も朝 その時間になって
また一つ村を回ってきて
また自分のところに戻ると
だから食事をもらうかもらわないか全然気にもしなかったんですね
で そこで 3ヶ月間も食べ物なくなるとね
まあ死にますからね しかし
このケタの方にね 馬をね
持って商人がいてね 馬を馬の商人で
だから自分が育てた馬たちを持って
金持ちに売ろうかなと思ってたところで
このウェーランジャー街を通っていくんですけどし
そちらに来たら雨季になっちゃったんですね
だからまあ動かないんです
それだったら馬たちと一緒に雨が上がるまで待とうと
雨季ですから そこを 3ヶ月間待たなくちゃいけ
3ヶ月間には 4ヶ月間も雨なので動かないんですね
そこでまた別な地方からね
お坊さんたちもお釈迦様が来て泊まっているということで
で 食事は食べ物はないとその馬の商人がわかって
馬の商人は人間はもうそんなにたくさんいるわけじゃないんですよ
馬の餌はいっぱいあったんですね
で 馬に食べさせるために
このまあ何かの穀物をね
[音楽]この高価な馬たちだから
草ばっかし食べさせるわけじゃなくて
この体力を作るためには
いろいろ穀物食べさせたりする
それでたくさんの馬たちがいるんですから
穀物は大量にその人は運んでいくんです
そうすると こっちはお坊さんたちにも一部分けてあげるということで
毎日食事分ぐらいの穀物をその人が分けてあげるんですね
そこもそんな量があなかったし
そこはお坊さんたち お釈迦様赤いもの作ってもいいということになったんだから
それを粉にしておかゆを作って
ちょっとおかゆにして
もう 3ヶ月とかそこばっかり飲んでいたんですね
それで暗号終わったら
その招待したバラモンさんの家に行ってね
もう暗号終わりましたから
これから帰ってもよろしいでしょうと言って帰ったんですね
帰ってまたウェサーリに
ウェサーリじゃなく西京に戻ったら
西京の人々 国がほとんどご供養だから
お釈迦様が参ったということ
かなりごちそうを作って奉仕したんですね
そこで 50人ぐらいのお坊さんたちがいて
もう 3ヶ月間食い物がなかったんだからね
無茶ごちそう食べちゃって興奮しちゃって
もう ふざけてものすごいだらしない
走り回るは川に飛び込んで遊ぶわとかね
で そういうことで大騒ぎになっちゃったんですね
元気でもう相撲をやるわとかね
そういうことで まあなんていうことかとね
他のお坊さんたちがね
3ヶ月間も食べ物がなくていたってすごく落ち着いていまして
すごいもう最高のごちそうを召し上がっていても
何のことなくいるんだよと
この性格の差は何なのか
それはやっぱり悟りに達している人と達していない人の差ですよと
もう悟りに達していない人にはいろいろ欲求があるんだよ
欲望があるんだよと だからごちそうを食べることになっちゃって
喜んじゃって 舞い上がっちゃって
もう感動しちゃって 苦しかったな
トベランジャの街ではとかね
という話だそうですね
まあそれぐらいのストーリーで
とにかくこの悟りに達するということは
まあかなりあれこれとかは
まあ無常たる世界では無常たる体に対しては要求期待はしないということなんです
それにもつなげてジャータカ物語もありましてね
まあ昔々バラナシ王がね
政権やってた時は まあ戦争
地方でね まあ何か反乱が起きて
で これを治めるために王様が軍隊を持って行くと言って反乱を抑えるんですね
随分簡単に そこで馬たちは結構仕事をしたんだから
苦労したんだから 馬たちにもご褒美をあげなくちゃいけないんだと
馬には給料をあげたって意味がないんだからね
それでたくさんブドウを集めてもらって
ブドウを潰してジュースを作って馬たちに飲ませるんです
まあ一応ブドウ酒というかね
とにかくもう戦争に持っていくんだからね
動物にも時々酒を飲ませたりはしますよ
それでもブドウ酒というか
ブドウの 100% のブドウのジュースを飲んで
馬たちは何のことなく落ち着いているんですね
それで大量にカスが残ったんです
搾りかすが 王様はね これはどうしますかと
すごい大量に搾りかすがあるんですからと
それはこの馬たちだけじゃなくて
ロバもたくさん連れて行くんです
ロバたちは荷車を引くんですね
馬は戦争を戦わなくちゃいけないんだから
荷物を運んだりすることはできないし
すごい勢いで走ったりして敵を倒さなくちゃいけないでしょう
だから馬たちの餌やら軍人の食べ物やらね
武器やら全部車にたくさん荷車に載せてくれて
それはロバたちは後ろから引いてくるんです
ゆっくりゆっくりと やっぱりロバたちは戦争しなかったんですけど
ロバたちもちゃんと仕事をしたんだからね
このカスをね ロバたちに食べなさい
食べさせなさいと言うと
そのままは食べられないんだから
そこをまた水を入れてごちゃごちゃにして飲めるようにして
ロバたちに飲ませたんですね
ロバたちはこのブドウのカスを飲んでから鳴くは大騒ぎするは興奮するはもう大変でしたと
もう酔っ払って だからみんな不思議で
本物を飲んだ馬たちは随分おとなしくて品格よくいるのに
この水で溶かしたものをカズを飲んだこの連中はこの性格は何なのか
まあそれはロバと馬の差だよと
いわゆる人格というかね
まあそういう物語というのは
やっぱり人格者が興奮したり
余計に感情を引き起こしたり
涙流してね もう感動ということはなくて
いつでも冷静にいるんだよということを言うために
使っているエピソードなんですね
やっぱり仏教はすごく大人しく落ち着いていることはすごくありがたいことだと思っているんですね
あまりこの激しくお祭りやったり
興奮したりするということは
まあ品がないことであると
まあそれでこの芸で言っているそこでも会うことはいますけど
やっぱり 普通冷静にいるということはね
すごい正確なんですね
例えば自分が期待すると
やっぱり涼しくなってほしいとかね
冷静がなくなるんで 例えば部屋に入ったと
せっかく外から部屋に入ったんだから
やっぱり涼しいでしょうなと期待してあったところで
涼しいどころかかなり蒸し暑くて
あー嫌だこの部屋は蒸し暑くてすぐ泣いちゃうでしょうね
じゃあ何とかしましょう
窓でも開けてください
冷房ないのかとかね いろいろ興奮しちゃうんですね
あるいは期待通りに入った部屋はかなり冷房が効いていると
ああ 気分がいいなんて天国に行ったみたいとかいろいろ言うでしょうね
あれで人格じゃないよということはもうよく分かりますね
だからこの人格者っていうのは別に何も期待してはないんですね
外に出るともう暑い まあまあ外は暑いなというぐらいで終わっちゃうんですね
で 部屋に入ったら これは涼しい
それで落ち着いているんです
外は暑いし 部屋の中もかなり暑いなと
暑い場合 そこでデータを取っただけで終わっちゃうんですね
なんだこれはということはないんですね
なんだこれは出てくると
やっぱり期待が働いてるんですね
欲が働いてるんですね
悟りに達している人というのは
その欲 欲が働かないんですね
だからまあ早々捨する落ち着きがあるっていう
はい まあこんなところですけど
また行きますか それで終了しますかね
[紙の音]